Loops can be combined together with each other
and with functions to make code both readable and versatile.
In this case, we will show a nested For loop.
A nested For loop is a loop inside another loop.
When we hit the first For statement, we define
the value iX as equal to the first value of the array in the loop declaration.
In this case, the array is an array of doubles.
And the value of the first element of the array is 1.
When we hit the second For statement, we define the second variable.
In this case, the variable is iY.
iY will be set equal to the first value of the array
in this loop&#39;s declaration.
In this case, the array is an array of cells.
iY is, therefore, a cell.
The first time through the loop, the cell has the array of characters, LEGO.
Now the code calls for a function that takes two variables and does something.
Our function juggles one LEGO brick.
Note that, in this case, the function is not
returning any values when it&#39;s done.
When we hit the first End statement, we repeat the innermost For loop.
The value of iX has not changed.
Only the value of iY has changed.
In this case, the second value in our array is a cell with the word &quot;apple.&quot;
Again, the loop passes the values over to the function.
And the function juggles one apple.
When the end is hit this time, there are no more values in iY array.
Now live proceeds to the next line of code, which is another End
statement, this time for the outermost loop.
Now we increment the value in iX to the second element
of the array, the value 3.
The next line of code is a declaration for the inner
For loop, which we will now run again.
The fact that we ran this before has no influence on how the loop will run now.
The first time we go through the loop, iY
will still become a cell with the word LEGO.
The loop passes its values to function.
The function juggles three LEGOs.
The second time the loop runs, the function juggles three apples.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Now we hit our End statement.
And the code updates the iX value.
There is only one more element in the array,
so this is the last time we will execute the outermost loop.
This time, the value is set to 84. iX will have a value of 84,
and iY will have the value LEGO.
As always, it&#39;s not a bad idea to have your function check to make sure
that the values are reasonable.
[MUSIC PLAYING]